[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
زياره مرتقبه للرئيس الصيني الى روسيا
ولندن تؤكد
الترحيب ببكي لذا استعادت السلامه في
اوكرانيا
تكشف عن موافقه ايران على وقف تسليح الحوت
طهران امام اختبار حقيقي
ضوابط جديده لنظام ايقاف الخدمات في
السعوديه
في الرابعه ايضا
الضغوط الدوليه على التيك توك تتواصل
نيوزيلندا تحضره لاجل المخاوف الامنيه
وجدت تعيش تظاهره الفورمولا 1 فعاليات
مصاحبه والاحد اجازه رسميه للطلاب
والطالبه
نبدا مباشره بمتابعه هذه الصور حيث دخل
قبل قليل رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان للمثول امام محكمه في مدينه
لاهور لدعم التماس قدمه ضد مذكره اعتقاله
اليوم وذلك وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده بدات
هذه الاجراءات ضد عمران خان بعد اقالته من
منصبه في تصويت برلماني مبكر العام الماضي
وصدرت ايضا مذكره توقيف بحقه من قبل محكمه
في اسلام اباد بعد فشله في المثول امام
المحكمه ثم تخان تتمثل في التربح من بيع
هدايا قدمها كبار الشخصيات الاجنبيه للدول
عندما كان رئيسا للوزراء بين عامي 2018
و2022
ثلاثه ايام تفصيلنا عن زياره المرتقبه
والتاريخيه لرئيس الصيني الى روسيا ردود
فعل تتواصل منذ اعلان الخرجات الصينيه
موعد زياره المقرره الاثنين المقبل رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني
المملكه المتحده سترحب بالصين اذا نجحت في
استعاده السلام باوكرانيا قال السونا كان
على الرئيس الصيني ان يستغل زيارته الى
موسكو لتشجيع الرئيس بوتين على الانسحاب
مضيفا بان بريطانيا ستواصل دعوه الصين الى
حد بوتين على سحب قوته من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
وكانت الخارجيه الصينيه اعلنت ان الرئيس
شيلنج سيزور موسكو بين العشرين واثنين
والعشرين مارس الجاري بدعوه من الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ومن جهه اقاله
الكرملين ان الرئيس الروسي بوتين سيبحث مع
نظيره الصيني ترسيخ التعاون الاستراتيجي
والشراكه الكامله بين البلدين خلال زياره
شي جين بينج الى موسكو
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه
اكد بان الرئيسين الصيني والروسي حافظ على
علاقه وثيقه ورسم مسارا للنمو المستدد
المستدامه وضع نموذجا جديدا للعلاقات
الدوليه حسب ما جاء على لسانه
في السنوات الاخيره حافظ الرئيس شيشي جين
بينك والرئيس بوتين على علاقه وثيقه لقد
رسم مسارا وقدم التوجيه للنمو المستدام
والسليم والمضطرد للشراكه الاستراتيجيه
الشامله بين الصين وروسيا والتنسيق العصر
الجديد لقد وجد الجانبان طريقا للعلاقات
القطريه الرئيسيه يتسم بالثقه
الاستراتيجيه والتعاون ووضع نموذج جديد
للعلاقات الدوليه
واضاف المتحدث باسم وزاره الخرجات الصينيه
بان الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا واستراليا
تنخرط فيه عصابه انجلوس
عقليه الحرب البارده ما يؤثر على الامن
والسلم الاقليميين والعالميين وفق التعبير
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا واستراليا
تنخرط في عصابه انجلوساكسونيه حيث اقامت
ما يسمى بشراكه امنيه ثلاثيه وتعزز
التعاون في الغواصات النوويه وغيرها من
التقنيات العسكريه المتطوره هذه حاله
النموذجيه لعقليه الحرب البارده الامر
سيكون له تاثيرات خطيره على السلام والامن
الاقليميين والعالميين
من ابو ظبي ينضم الينا بالتالي فيديانينا
المتحدث باسم سفاره اوكرانيا في الامارات
العربيه المتحده سيد فيتالي مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه كيف تنظر لزياره الرئيس
الصيني الى موسكو في هذا التوقيت وفي هذا
المسار الذي تشهده الحرب في اوكرانيا
السلام عليكم
نحن
طبعا نراقب هذه الزياره عن كافه لان نعرف
ان هذه سياره متعلقه بالمحادثات
بمحادثات السلام في اوكرانيا
واذا تحدثنا عن مفاوضات السلام
ونريد ان نذكر للصين ولروسيا والعالم كله
عن قرار الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده تم
اعتماده قبل ثلاث اسابيع
وتم اتخاذها باصوات 141 دوله والذي يدعو
الى الانسحاب الحضوري للدوله روسيه من
الاعراض الاوكرانيه ومواقفه المسلمين
واعاده العداله ويصطنب هذا القرار على
صيغه السلام الاوكرانيه التي طرحها رئيس
الاوكراني ومنذ هذه الفتره نعتقد ان اي
مبادره صينيه
يعني صدر من عن اي دوله اخرى اي خطط
السلام من اي دوله يجب ان تنتقل للقرار
المذكور للجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
كيف ترون او تقراون تاثير
وتداعيات هذه الزياره الان على الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه
اهم شيء نحن لازم
ان نعرف ان اوكرانيا لم تختار هذه الحرب
روسيا هذه الحرب العدوانيه على اوكرانيا
ولكن العراق على كل صعوبات صمدت اوكرانيا
في وجه هذا الغزو روسيا الاستعماري ولا
تظل تقوم بالنجاح وستواصل التحرير ارضها
يعني بجميع الوسائل المتاحه والاسلحه يعني
منها كل شيء من الاعراض الاوكرانيه تم
تحفيرها بابطالنا بالاسلحه ونحن ندعو الى
المزيد من هذه الاسلحه نحن نحتاج الى هذه
الاسلحه خاصه ثقيله مثل الطائرات
والدبابات لان هذه المواجهه مرتبطه بوجودك
الدوله هذه هي الحرب مصريه بالنسبه لنا
ونحن دائما نسمع من موسكو التصريحات خطيره
يعني حتى البربريه عن ضروره اوكرانيا بشكل
كامل ومع يعني سقوط اوكرانيا كدوله وهو
اختفاؤها من خريطه دول العالم وما عندنا
يعني خيار اخر سوى ضفار عن نفسنا ووطننا
انه حقنا
وواجبنا المقدس ونحن نحتاج للاسلحه وكل ما
اسرع الدول العالم وشركائه في تزويد
اوكرانيا للاسلحه المطلوبه لصد العدوان
الروسي كلما ازدادت قدرات القوات المسلحه
على البحر الاحتلال والانتصار وانهاء هذه
الحرب هذا ما
يحتاجه العالم الحديث اليوم عن اتصال
افتراضي ربما
متوقع سيجمع الرئيس الصيني بالرئيس
الاوكراني هل من معلوماته وتاكيدات على
مثل هذا الاتصال وهل يمكن للمقترحات
الصينيه التي تم الحديث عنها مؤخرا تكون
مثالا حديثه والنقاش بين الجانبين الصيني
والاوكراني
نعم نحن بننتظر التاكيد على اجراء هذا
الاتصال
وطبعا يعني ممكن يعني نرحب ان ان كانت هذا
الاتصال ولكنني اكرر من جديد ان يعني
بالرغم عن جميع الاتصالات يعني حتى مع
الصين
لا ولن تصوم اوكرانيا على حقها في استعاده
وحده اراضينا لا يمكن من المصومه على مبدا
سلامه الاقليميه يجب على اوكرانيا والعالم
كله ارسال رساله واضحه الى جميع المواطنين
المحتملين
ومفردها ان العدوان سيدمر دوله المعتادة
نفسها
لهذا السبب يجب محاسبه روسيا على الطريق
عن طريق دفع او اداره وانشاء المحكمه
الخاصه لمراقبه المجرمين الروس اوكرانيا
اكرر ان لن تصوم على وحده اراضيها بغض
النظر عن جميع الاتصالات عندما يكون
الكريم لان هذه
الزياره تاتي في اطار
تعزيز الشراكه الكامله واستكمال ايضا شركه
استراتيجيه بين بين
البلدين هل في ذلك ما يقلق كييف بان تتجه
ربما بكيني الى دعم كامل
لروسيا في هذه الحرب سياسيا عسكريا وغيرها
شكرا جزيلا لك من ابو ظبي في تالين
المتحدث باسم سفاره اوكرانيا في الامارات
العربيه المتحده
في اخر التطورات الدعم لاوكرانيا اعلن
رئيس الوزراء السلوفاكي ادوارد هيجر بان
الحكومه الزلباكيه وافقت على ارسال طائرات
مقاتله من طراز ميج 29 الى اوكرانيا ما
زاد من مساعدتها العسكريه الى وقد اعلنت
سلوفاكيا المجاوره لبولندا منذ العام
الماضي نيته ارسال الطائرات ميغا 29
للمساعده في تعويض الخسائر في مخزونات
اوكرانيا الحاليه لانه لم يتم اتخاذ
قرارات النهائيه بهذا الشان منذ ذلك الحين
اذكروا ان اسطول الطائرات ميغا 29 قد توقف
عن العمل صيف الماضي ومعظمها ليس في حاله
تشغيليه
وفي اول رد روسي على تزويد اوكرانيا
بمقاتلات من بولندا وسلوفاكيا توعد
الكرملين بتدمير اي عتاد تقدمه الدولتان
وقال لها بيان الرئاسه الروسيه من اهميه
المقاتلات التي تقدم لاوكرانيا مشيرا الى
انها قديمه وغير ضروريه وفقا للبيع
قبل ذلك اعلنت السويد عن صفقه لبيع نظامها
من سلاح المدفعيه الذاتيه الى بريطانيا
ذاتيه الحركه الى بريطانيا ما يتيح نظام
المدفعيه الاقدم اي اس 90 الذي تملكه الى
اوكرانيا وقالت الحكومه السويديه في
بيانها ان بريطانيا
افادت في يناير بانها سترسل نظام ارتشر
مباشره الى اوكرانيا دون تحديد العدد
لكنها اكدت الخميس ارسالها ثمان وحدات
نظام ارتشر الذي تطوره السويد هو مدفعه
الي بالكامل مثبت على مركبه مدرعه صالحه
لكل الطرق يتم تشغيله عن بعد بتقنيات
متطوره
ميدانيا نشر معهد دراسات الحرب الامريكي
معلومات جديده منسوبه الى قائد فاجنرزعموا
فيها بان هناك خططا لتصفيته وتصفيه
مجموعته في اوكرانيا سواء قبل نهايه حرب
اوكرانيا او بعدها معلومات معهد دراسات
الحرب تستند الى نقاش المزعوم بين الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين وسكرتيري مجلس الامن
الروسي نيكولاي باتروشيف بشان مستقبل
مجموعه فاجنر وفي هذا السياق يزعم قائد
فاجنر بان باترو شيب حضر الرئيس بوتين من
مخاطر قيام مجموعه
بتكوين قوه اكبر تمكنها من احتلال اراض
على حدود اوكرانيا وربما حتى التقدم داخل
روسيا يذكر
هو ضابط مخابرات رفيع وامين سري مجلس
الامن الاتحادي الروسي
نتابع مع ضيفنا من كيبل الصحفي محمد
البابا السيد محمد اهلا وسهلا بك معي ايضا
في نشر الاعلان من سلوفاكيا عن تسليم هذه
الطائرات ميج تسعه
وعشرين
وموقف الكريم منها باعتبارها قديمه وغير
ضروريه هل له اي اصدافك
نعم بالفعل وايضا يعني جاء بالامس ايضا
اعلان ان بولندا سلمت اربع طائرات من نوع
الى الجانب الاوكراني الاسبوع الماضي هذا
شكل دعم معنوي كبير للقوات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه واصداؤه يعني كانت ملموسه عبر
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وعبر وسائل
الاعلام الاوكرانيه التي رحبت بهذه الخطوه
لا بل طالبت جميع الدول التي يعني تريد او
تدرس امكانيه فيسبوك اوكرانيا بمقاتلات
مهما كان نوعها ان كانت مقاتلات امريكيه
تصنع او غربيه صنع او حتى سوفيتيه العهد
كما ايضا يعني خلال الفتره الماضيه بولندا
قدمت الى اوكرانيا قطع غيار لتشغيل
الطائرات الاوكرانيه التي كانت متوقفه
بسبب يعني نقص في العتاد وقطع الغيار وهذا
ساعد القوات الاوكرانيه يعني القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه تلعب دور كبير في بعض
العمليات يعني في منطقه في منطقه ذا
فاولوجيا تلعب دور والان يعني الهجوم
المضاد الذي يعد له الجيش الاوكراني هو
بحاجه لسلاح جو حتى تكون هناك تغطيه
الجويه للهجوم البري الذي يعد له الجيش
الاوكراني خاصه ان يعني الاليات
والعسكريات التي وعدت العسكريه والدبابات
التي وعدت بها اوكرانيا بدات تصل تباعا
الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه واصبح الجيش
الايراني يعني بين قوسين او ادنى من بدء
الهجوم المضاد الذي يعد له يتم الان
التسويق له اعلاميا عبر الاعلام الاوكراني
ووزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه والذي كما يزعم
انه سيكون يعني سيقلب الموازين في شرق
اوكرانيا لذلك كل المساعدات العسكريه التي
تحتاجها اوكرانيا هي نقطه ايجابيه يعني من
حيث الاصدار الاوكرانيه ايضا وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه اعلنت ان هناك عدد من الدول
الان تتخذ يعني في صدد اتخاذ قرار بتزويد
اوكرانيا بمقاتلات ستكون مؤثره مقاتلات
غربيه منها طائرات 1016 مثلا هولندا يعني
اعلنت استعدادها لتزويد اوكرانيا بطائرتي
اف 16 اضافه بولندا مستعده لتزويد الجيش
الاوكراني بجميع السلاح والعتاد الذي
يحتاجه محمد يعني هل بدات تتضح ملامح الان
هذا الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد وفقا لما وصل
ربما الى الارض من هذه الامدادات بالاسلحه
من دول
الغرب هل هي كافيه هل هي قادره على قلب
موازين القوى على الارض هل يمكن
لهذه الزياره التي يقوم بها الرئيس الصيني
الان ان تغير من كل يعني هذه التحركات وفق
مقترحات معينه يمكن ان تعرض له
نعم لقراءه ما يجري على ارض الواقع الجيش
الاوكراني بدا يستوعب الهجوم الكبير الذي
بداته قبل فتره على مدينه ضخمه وقد راينا
ان وضع يعني جبهه باخموت بدا يخف من حده
شده العمليات العسكريه لذلك يمكن قول ان
الجيش الاوكراني استوعب الصدمه الهجوم
الصادم من القوات الروسيه وبدا باستنزاف
القوه الضاربه الروسيه لانهاء الجيش
الروسي حتى يبدا بهجومه يعني بالهجوم
المضاد الذي يسوق له اعلاميا وكما ذكرت
انه قريب اما يعني الجانب الاوكراني يعول
على الزياره التي يقوم بها الرئيس الصيني
لتسويق خطه السلام يعني الاوكرانيه التي
يعني عرضها الرئيس الاوكراني وايضا كما
يتداول انه سيكون ربما سيكون هناك اجتماع
افتراضي بين الرئيس الاوكراني والرئيس
الصيني سيتم خلاله سيلينسكي سيقوم بطرح
وتسويق لخطته خطه السلام التي طرحها والتي
من خلالها تستطيع اوكرانيا وقف هذه الحرب
بعد يعني في حال التزمت روسيا بهذه الشكل
الان هي لغه الميدان حتى هذه اللغه
الوحيده المتداوله بين اوكرانيا وروسيا هي
الحرب في ساحه القتال الجيش الاوكراني
الان بدا بسبب الاسلحه التي بدا يحصل
عليها وان استمرت وتيره تسليم الاسلحه كما
يعني كما بدات قبل اسبوع او 10 ايام يمكن
القول انه خلال شهر على الاكثر سيكون
الجيش الاوكراني او سيمتلك الجيش
الاوكراني روح المبادره والعزيمه للتقدم
خاصه في محور الذي يعتبر الان المحور
الرئيسي ولا ننسى ان الاداره الاوكرانيه
غيرت الحاكم العسكري لمقاطعه حتى يكون
هناك قياده جديده قد تستطيع يعني تحرير
تلك المقاطعه او اجزاء التي خسرتها
اوكرانيا من تلك المقاطعه بعد تاريخ
الرابع والعشرين شكرا
الصحفي محمد الباب
شكرا شكرا
ومتابعه لقضيه اسقاط روسيا مسيرتنا
امريكيه فوق البحر الاسود اكدت المتحدثه
باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا خروف
الموسكو لا تسعى للمواجهه مع الولايات
المتحده بعد حادثه الطائره المسيره وقالت
زخروبه ان بلادها تعتقد ان من المهم
الابقاء على خطوط الاتصال مفتوحه وانها لا
تسعى للمواجه كما اكدت ان روسيا تدافع عن
التعاون البراجمتي لصالح الشعوبي بين
البلدين وانها تعرف كيف تحمي هذه المصالح
من جهتها نقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه تدرس
تقييم رحلاتها في البحر الاسود تجنبا لاي
تصعيد محتمل مع روسيا اضاف المسؤولون
الامريكيون ان البنتاجون يبحث طرقا بديله
لتفادي المقاتلات الروسيه في شبه جزيره
القرم كما سيدرس البنتاجون الاعتماد على
الاقمار الصناعيه لجمع المعلومات في منطقه
البحر الاسود
هذا وقال المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كير بين الفيديو الذي عرضته
واشنطن عن اسقاط المسيرات الامريكيه فوق
البحر الاسود يفند كذبه روسيا
هذا الفيديو حاسم للغايه حول ما حدث انه
يفند تماما الكذبه الروسيه حول ما تحدثوا
عنه وما لم يتحدثوا انه امر رائع وواضح
جدا عندما تنظر الى هذا الفيديو تلك
المقاتله ضربت طائرتنا المسيره
وكانت قياده القوات الامريكيه في اوروبا
نشرت مقطعا مصورا لعمليه اسقاط مسيرتها من
قبل القوات الروسيه فوق البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
وفي الشق الاقتصاديه للحرب اكادير الكريم
لان روسيا قررت تمديد اتفاق الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود لمده 60 يوما ماكدا تصريحات
سابقه لوزاره الخارجيه من جهتها كانت
اوكرانيا طالبت وفق الاتفاق الذي سينتهي
قريبا بضروره تجديده بالكامل بموجب الشروط
الحاليه التي تنص على مده تمديد تصل الى
120 يوما وليس 60 يوما
في الرابعه بعد قليل
هنري يشيد بدوري السعوديه في تحقيق
التوازن للوضع الاستراتيجي في الشرق
الاوسط
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه الاسبق هنري في مقابله مع صحيفه
واشنطن انه يرى تغييرا جوهريا في الوضع
الاستراتيجي في الشرق الاوسط وان السعوديه
تقوم بموازنه امنها بتنوع التحالفاتها
تصريحات اشارت الاتفاق بين السعوديه
وايران بوساطه وقال ان الصين اعلنت في وقت
سابق ان تكون شريكا في النظام العالمي
الجديد قال انه بهذه الوساطه بين الرياض
والطيران تقوم بخطوه مهمه في هذا الاتجاه
اضافه بان دور الصين كصانعه سلام في
المنطقه يغير ما وصفه بشروط المرجعيه في
الدبلوماسيه الدوليه
التصعيد في اليمن الى سؤال عريض صاحب
الاتفاق السعوديه الايراني الذي اعلن
بوساطه صينيه في الحادي عشر من مارس الجري
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بالفرحان جدد بالامس الدعوه لبدء العمليات
السياسيه بين الحكومه اليمنيه والحوثين ما
كشفت صحيفه وولز جورنال عن موافقه ايران
على وقف تسليح الخوطيين في اطار الاتفاق
على استئناف العلاقات مع السعوديه مشيره
ايضا الى ان نهجه ايران حيال الصراع في
اليمن سيكون اختبارا حقيقيا لنواياها بعد
عوده العلاقات مع الرياض
ضم الينا من لندن الكاتب الصحفي في جريده
الشرق الاوسط بدر القحطاني حياك الله بدر
معي في نشره الرابعه
يعني عندما تقول
حسب مسؤولين امريكيين والسعوديين ايران
وافقت على وقف ارسال شحنات الاسلحه الى
حلفائها الحوثيين في اليمن كجزء من الصفقه
ربما يعني هل يعني ذلك اولا ان ايران
اعترفت بالفعل بانها هي من تقوم بامداد
الحوثيين بالاسلحه وهو الامر الذي كانت
تنكره مرارا يعني في السابق هل ستتوقف
فعلا عن ذلك هل يعتبر ذلك ايضا موقفا
متقدما من ايران في تعاملها مع الميليشيات
اليوم
بكل تاكيد مساء الخير عليك وعلى الساده
المشاهدين اعتقد ان الايران في الجولات
الاولى في المحادثات التي عقدت سواء في
بغداد او غيرها من العواصم والمدن مع
السعوديه كانت في البدايه تنكر مساله
الاسلحه ونحن جميعا نعرف ان الاسلحه لا
يتم زرعها ولا يتم
ايجادها من تحت الارض يتم تهريبها الى
داخل اليمن عن طريق البحر او البر وفقا
لتقارير الدوليه وابرزها تقرير خبراء
بمجلس الامن مساله ان ان الملف اليمني
سيكون هو الاختبار وبالفعل اختبار حقيقي
وملموس واختبار افعال لا اقوال الاقوال
الايرانيه بعد الاتفاق ايجابيا وبمجرد
التزامه بمساله عدم تصريح الحوثيين كما
تفضلت هو اعتراف مبدئي وهذا خطوه وهذه
خطوه متقدمه بقيت الكره الان في ملعب
الحوثيين الذين حتى داعميهم الايرانيين
بدون حل الازمه اليمنيه على الاقل وفقا
للروايه الرسميه الايرانيه اعتقد ان
الحوثيين حتى الان لم يصرحوا بموقفهم تجاه
بشكل يعني واضح محمد عبد السلام المتحدث
باسم جماعه انصار
الحوثيين طبعا علق في تغريده على تويتر
دون ذكر الاتفاق بشكل صريح بان المنطقه
بحاجه لعوده العلاقات الطبيعيه بين الدوله
يزيد ذلك من غموض موقف هذه الميليشيات
تجاهها الاتفاق الا يمكن اعتباره ايضا
جزءا من تبادل الادوار بين ايران
والمليشيا الحوثيه في المنطقه الان
اعتقد هناك حتى لا ننسى هناك وساطه تجريها
السعوديه بمشاركه عمانيه مع الحوثيين وانا
وكثير من المراقبين معي يؤمنون تماما
بقدره السعوديه على اقناع الحوثيين على
مساله الهدنه وعلى مساله
البدء في المفاوضات السياسيه وايضا البنود
التي تتضمنها الهدنه الامميه الاخيره التي
رفضها الحوثيون في اكتوبر الماضي كنا في
نهايه العام تحدثنا عن ابواب السعوديه
واقفال ايران في الازمه اليمنيه فتحت
السعوديه ابواب عديده لحل هذه الازمه من
ضمنها الحوار مع ايران والان توج هذا
الحوار وايران هي التي ساعدت اليه في
البدايه بالمناسبه
بالاتفاقيه الاخيره والتي مازالت قيداء
الاختبار والامتحان هناك ابواب اخرى عديده
فتحتها السعوديه مثل الوساطه بين الحوثيين
والحكومه اليمنيه بمشاركه عمانيه هناك
ايضا دعم المسار الام خصوصا المبعوث
الاممي الى اليمن هانز جراند بيرج وجهوده
في مختلف الملفات ومن ضمنها
الحوار الذي يحصل هذه الايام في جنيف فيما
يتعلق في ملف الاسرى والمعتقلين هناك كما
تفضل وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الاسبق هناك
توازن استراتيجي تقوده السعوديه في
المنطقه والكل يعلم ان سياسه السعوديه
دائما سياسه دائما تنمويه
واعتقد ان هذا الزخم السعودي هذه المره
راينا زخم الامريكي لمده عامين لم ينجح في
اليمن اعتقد ان الزخم السعودي وزخم
الخليجي في اليمن سوف يكلل بالنجاح اذا ما
اراد اليمنيون انفسهم سواء الحوثيين او
الحكومه اليمنيه التي ابدت بالمناسبه انها
تراقب
الافعال الايرانيه وليس الاقوال الايرانيه
بحذر فهذا الكثير من تحيط بالموضوع لانه
شكوك ما تزال يعني يعني حول موقف ايران من
الحوثيين من ميليشياتها في المنطقه بشكل
عام
قلت بانه جنيف مثلا ما يحدث فيها اليوم هو
ليس مجرد صدفه لابد بانه نتيجه للاثار او
اثار اوليه الاتفاق بين السعوديه وايران
برعايه صيني الى اي مدى يمكن ان يتقدم هذا
الملف والاسئله الاخرى المتعلقه عن موضوع
كذلك مصير الاسلحه اصلا الموجوده بيد
الحوثيين من صواريخ من طائرات مسيره
ايرانيه الصنع تهدد بها ممرات الدوليه
البحريه وغيرها من الامور يعني خلال فتره
الماضي
اذا كان هناك عزيزي خالد شيء تعلمناه في
الازمه اليمنيه فهو نتفاءل ولكن الا نفرط
في
المشكله ايضا اذا حتى لو كان القيادات
خصوصا على مستوى مثلا الحوثيين هم ليسوا
حزبا سياسيا وليس لديهم ذلك التنظيم القوي
مجرد يعني مجموعه وهناك
قيادات خصوصا من حزب الله هي التي تقود
مساله الشؤون السياسيه والاعلاميه وما الى
ذلك فبالتالي حتى لو كانت هناك توجيهات من
القيادات فانعكاسها على الارض لا يكون
سريعا فبالتالي نحن لا نفرض في التفاؤل
ولكن الزخم الموجود يدعو الى التامل
والترقب لان كل خطوه ايجابيه سوف تنعكس
بشكل كبير جدا على 30 مليون يمني يعيشون
كابوس الانقلاب منذ العام 2014 وايضا على
مختلف الصعد الاقتصاديه والتجاريه اليمنيه
هناك حاله من الشلل التجاري والاقتصادي
في المقابل نرى ان هذا النوع من
الاجتماعات رانا هذا النوع من
الاتفاقات التي او التوازنات التي تقودها
السعوديه في المنطقه سيصب بالخير على
اليمن واليمنيين ولكن هذا لن يثمر شيئا
اذا لم
يتنازل الحوثيين اذا لم يقدموا انفسهم
جماعه سياسيه تجلس في طاوله مفاوضات
وتحافظ على بعض المكاسب التي حصلت عليها
وايضا الحكومه اليمنيه قدمت الكثير من
التنازلات
واعتقد انه يطلب منهم المزيد حتى حقنا
للدماء وتحقيقا لانهاء هذه الازمنه لا
تنسى الازمه اليمنيه اذا انتهت هناك هل هل
الوقائم ينتظر هل الوقت الان يعني هو
وقت مناسب خاصه وان الكثير اليوم يرون بان
ايران لا يمكن ان تتخلى عن حلفائها
وميليشياتها وفق اصلا مبدا اساسي في
دستورها يعني موجود وينص عليه ومبني عليه
هذا نظاميه تراهن على الوقت ربما تحاول ان
تغير في تكتيكات هذه المعركه تهدئ خاصه
انها تتدرب فبالتالي الطرف الاخر وهنا
اتحدث عن السعوديه وعن الصين
هل هناك ادراك لذلك بمعنى ان هناك وقت
واضح وصريح يجب ان تحسم فيه بعض الملفات
للتقدم خطوه نحو ملفات اعمق واكبر
نحن عندما نقرا القراءات التي
تخرج من وكالات الانباء العالميه ومن
مراكز التفكير هناك حديث عن ان ايران
اصبحت في ورطه ورطه داخليه ورطه مع
الاوروبيين ورطه مع المجتمع الدولي ورطه
مع الجيران فبالتالي حتى ولو كان هذا
الموضوع مرحله بالنسبه الى ايران لابد من
اعطائه فرصه لماذا لان اذا كان هناك دوله
تقود السلام والتنميه فلا بد ان يتذوق
الايرانيون قليلا من هذا
يكون هناك
نموذج للقياده الايرانيه لان ترى كيف تكون
الثمار حسن الجوار وكيف تكون ثمار
العلاقات الجيده الخلافات ستكون موجوده
ولا تنتهي ولا اعتقد انها ستصل حتى الى
مرحله التحالفات وفقا للتسريبات الاخيره
لكن مساله التعايش ومساله
ضروره الظروف الحاليه قد تكون ربما وقتيه
ولكنها تمه لحاله افضل بكثير من حاله
الاستعداد التام حاله حتى الفجر في
الخصومه مساله ان ايران في ورطه هذه لا
غبار عليها نرى داخل الايراني مشتعرا نرى
ايران في اتفاق النووي معطله نرى ان هناك
ضغوط غربيه عليها فيما يتعلق سواء بحقوق
الانسان فيما يتعلق بكثير من الملفات اضف
الى ذلك كله حرمانها من 30 مليار دولار
امريكي شهريا
من تصدير النفط فهذه الضغوطات كلها تجعل
النظام وربما السجالات الداخليه في النظام
هي التي سوف تعرقله ما لم يكن ويعتقد انها
ستجد كل الخير اذا احسنت والتزمت بالشروط
التي شكرا
جزيلا من لندن الكاتب الصحفي في جريده
الشرق الاوسط بدر القحطاني
في الرابعه بعد قليل
جدتها تعيش تظاهرات فورملا 1 فعاليات
مصاحبه ولا حد اجازه رسميا للطلاب
والطالبات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قرات السعوديه ضوابط
جديده خاصه بمعالجه طلبات ايقاف الخدمات
من ابرزها انشاء المنصه الالكترونيه
الموحده وايضا تنفيذ الجهات الحكوميه
للقرار خلال مده لا تتجاوز 180 يوما
اقرت السعوديه ضوابط محدثه لنظام ايقاف
الخدمات وهو اجراء يترتب عليهم امتناع
جهات حكوميه عن تقديم الخدمات لفرد او
مؤسسه
وشملت الضوابط انشاء المنصه الالكترونيه
الموحده لايقاف الخدمات تشرف عليه 13 جهه
ومنظمه حكوميه واهليه من ضمنها هيئه حقوق
الانسان المنصه الموحده تمكن الفرد او
الجهه من طلب تمديد المده قبل ايقاف
الخدمات كما تتيح خيار وقف قرار الايقاف
والغائه خلال 24 ساعه فقط ايقاف الخدمات
المحدث لا يشمل العلاج والتعليم والعمل
والسجل التجاري وتوقيع الوقائع المدنيه
والاوراق الثبوتيه
واكدت الضوابط المحدثه على عدم تاثر
التابعين للشخص الموقوفه خدماته باي اضرار
180 يوما هي المده المحدده لجمع الجهات
لتطبيق ضوابط المحدثه لنظام ايقاف الخدمات
التي تراعي مصالح الموقوفين وتضمن مرونه
عاليه في الاجراءات
انضم الينا في استوديوهاتنا من رياض
المحاميه الدكتور محمد العيسى حياك الله
يعني اولا ما ميزه هذه الضوابط الجديده
ولماذا تتخذ في البدايه هي ضوابط يعني
خلينا ناخذ تصور عن فكره
الضوابط الدائمه والانظمه واهدافها دائما
في جميع الدول هي عمليه عاده تنظيميه يكون
الهدف منها يعني تحديد الممارسات بحيث انه
ما يكون في يعني نوع من التباين في الجهات
الاخرى او الجهات المسؤوله عن تطبيق هذا
هذه الضوابط سواء كانت حكوميه او غيرها
بحيث انه ما يكون في نوع من التعارض او
التباين او الاضطراب الهدف من هاي الضوابط
هي تحديد وتنظيم الممارسه السابقه في
موضوع فيما يتعلق في في ايقاف الخدمات
نلاحظ مثلا كانت في فترات من الفترات كان
يتضرر من ايقاف الخدمات التابعين مثلا
يتضرر الشخص نفسه
يستفيد منها الشخص سواء كان على المستوى
الفرد او على مستوى قطاع الاعمال فمثلا
بدلا ان تتقدم المنشفه في قطاع الاعمال
بطلب خدمه جديده هذه تكون المرحله الاولى
لكن لو كان نشاطها قائم تريد ان تتوسع فيه
مرحله التطبيقيه مرحله المرحله الاولى فقط
فهذا لا يخضع للقاف طيب ما استجاب وما
تعدلت الاشكاليه او الطلب المطلوب منه او
الى اخره في المرحله الاولى تنتقل
تنفيذ ايقاف الخدمات للمرحله التاليه
المرحله التاليه هي متوسط اثر يصير اي شيء
يتعلق بتوسيع النشاط ايضا يخضع لي ايقاف
خدمات انتهت المده ولم يتم معالجه
الاشكاليه من قبل
لايقاف الخدمات القابله للايقاف مع
التاكيد على استثناء الاثر
مع التاكيد على استثناء ما يتعلق بالاضرار
به او بالتابعين فيما يتعلق التعليم تطبيق
بيختلف اليوم يعني بعد النظام الجديد اليه
بيكون التطبيق عباره عن منصه الخاصه
الكترونيه لهذه الضوابط تخضع لاداره
وصلاحيات اللجنه اللجنه مكونه من اكثر من
ما يقارب 13 جهه حكوميه برئاسه وزاره
الداخليه
ومشاركه عدد من الجهات الحكوميه والوزارات
تتقدم الجهه الحكوميه بتقدير بطلب ايقاف
الخدمه وايقاف الخدمات بموجب نموذج معتمد
من اللجنه نفسها يوضح فيه سبب
الطلب هذه الطلبه الخدمات وايضا مستند
نظامي الضوابط اكدت على انه لا يتم ايقاف
الخدمات الا بموجب سند نظامي او قرار
قضائي او مرسوم ملكي او ما شابه ذلك فلا
يكون لايقاف الخدمات التي جعل وايضا اكدت
الضوابط على ان لا يكون ايقاف الخدمات
لغرض الطلب من المواطن او الفرد المراجعه
لا توقف الخدمه لاجل هذا فقط وانما هو
لاغراض اخرى ستطبق
يعني في القضايا الجديده
ام انه سيتم تطبيقها حتى على المتضررين
سابقا
تراجع ربما النص لا هو بيكون باثر رجعي
لكن في مرحله انتقاليه وايضا النص النص
الضابط في اخرها انه يكون
التطبيق هذه الضوابط بعد 180 يوم من نشره
نشرت اليوم فبعد 180 يوم تدخل في حيز
التنفيذ مثل اي ضوابط او قواعد يعني
معناته سيتم مراجعه كل القضايا السابقه
انما فيما يتعلق في من اوقف خدماته الان
فيكون يخضع الضابط الجديد شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور محمد العيسى المحامي ضيفي في شكرا
لك
تتزايد المصاعب التي تواجهها منصه تيك توك
في مختلف بلدان العالم في الولايات
المتحده خيرت مالكين منصه الصينيين بين
البيع او الحظر في وقت انضافت ايضا
نيوزيلندا والمملكه المتحده الى قائمه
البلدان التي حضرت تيك توك من اجهزتها
الحكوميه
حرب عالميه على التطبيق الصيني الاشهر
تحركات واسعه من الحكومات في جميع المناطق
لحظر او تقييد تيك توك في ظل مخاوف امنيه
متزايده البيع او الحظر بهذه الطريقه
تواصل واشنطن الضغط
الولايات المتحده تدفع المالكين الصينيين
للتخلي عن الشركه وان لم يحدث فان الحظر
سيكون مصيرا المنصه في الولايات المتحده
تقول اداره بايدن الحمله الامريكيه تعتبر
ان تيك توك يمنح السلطات الصينيه امكانيه
الوصول الى بيانات المستخدمين في جميع
انحاء العالم من جانبه رد تيك توك على
المطالب الامريكيه متحدث باسم المنصه
الصينيه قال ان بيع الاسهم لن يحل مشاكل
الامن القومي المتصوره فالطريقه الافضل
لمعالجه هذه المخاوف هي الشفافيه وحمايه
من داخل الولايات المتحده لانظمه وبيانات
المستخدمين الامريكيين يقول المتحدث باسم
تيك توك
دائره الحرب تتسع اكثر مع مرور الايام
المملكه المتحده هي الاخرى اعلنت حظرا
فوريا للتطبيق الصيني على الاجهزه
الحكوميه بسبب مخاوف متعلقه بالامن ايضا
وكذلك فعلت
دول كثيره اخرى ليستمر مسلسل تيك توك
بحلقات كثيره ومتداخله بلال البجداني
العربيه
ينضم الينا الباحث في امن المعلومات
والنظم الامنيه عادل الغامدي سيد عادل
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه انا ودي
اتكلم معك عن تيك توك في السعوديه يعني
تعرف بان منذ فتره خرج الكثير من الذين
يتحدثون او يطالبون بحظر تيك توك في كثير
من المنصات هناك الكثير من المغردين خاصه
من اولياء الامور من يطالب باتخاذ قرار
رسمي لكن حتى الان لا اعلان رسمي عن ذلك
هل من الضروري الان بالنسبه للسعوديه ان
تتخذ هذا القرار اسوه بقرارات الدول
الاخرى التي تتجه الى
نهارك سعيد حياك الله موضوع تيك توك
بالنسبه نمشي موضوع العالم موضوع اكثر من
ضجه اعلاميه امريكا هي دمنا مسيطره على
المعلومات
شاهد اكثر برامج التواصل الاجتماعي
تويتر كلها موجوده في امريكا هذا البرنامج
الصيني اتزوج اثنين مليار تحميل عن طريق
الانترنت عاده المستخدمين صعود مرتفع جدا
امريكا ما تعودت انه في برنامج خارج خارج
حدودها عندهم معلومات المستخدمين البرامج
المعلومات اللي بيجمعها تكتب تجمعها جميع
البرامج الاخرى
نفس المعلومات نفس كل شيء
كل اللي قاعد يصير انا اشوف انه هو مجرد
ضغط على الحكومه الصينيه لانها تبيع
البرنامج يا انه
يتم حظره امريكا ما اتوقع انه حيتم حظر
لانه المطالب اي ادعاءات موجوده على تيك
توك هي موجوده جميع وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعيه وتم الايضاح انه اصلا
المعلومات المستخدمين الخاصه بتيك توك
تخزن في خواتم خاصه موجوده داخل امريكا
والنسخ الاحتياطيه موجوده في دوله ماليزيا
من شركه تيك توك يقولوا لا انتم عندكم
صلاحيات وانه عندكم قانون الصيني يسمح اذا
الحكومه الصينيه طلبت من شركه تيك توك انه
تعطيها اي معلومات فشركه تيك توك مجبره
انها تعطي المعلومات هذه مش زي الشركات
الوضع فيها كيف يعني خاصه انه المطالبات
كلها تاتي من جانب اخلاق يعني
تجاوزات بغيرها من الامور الان
جميع التجاوزات موجوده في جميع البرامج
لو تطالع على سناب شات على تويتر على
فيسبوك يعني نمسك على اي برنامج ايش يقول
لك البرنامج هذا اقرا اللوائح حقه ممنوع
ممنوع ممنوع مثلا ممنوع الاباحيه وفي نفس
الوقت الاقي نفس المنصه هذه توثق حسابات
اشخاص معتمدين في المواضيع هذه ما هو منطق
تعارض واضح وصريح في مطالبات انه التيك
توك مشكلته انه بصراحه اغلب تعامله فئه
شباب واطفال بالفعل يعني حتى انا اشوف انه
احنا في السعوديه التوجه اخلاقي لانه
بالفعل الناس صارت تنتقد الاطفال بينزل
تيك توك
بيبدا يبث بيبدا يبث البيوت بيبدا بيبدا
يصور كل شيء الطفل ما يستوعب ما ما يفكر
يجي واحد يقول له بالله صور لي وجهك ابغى
اشوفهم طفل عمره سبعه ثمانيه سنين انا ما
اشوف انه الموضوع انه انت تحضر تطبق
التطبيق لازم توعل او الاطفال
يعني نفس وجهه النظر الغربيه يعني
المطالبات لان اصبحت في الكثير من دول من
دول العالم ليس امريكا فقط نتحدث عن
بريطانيا عن نيوزيلندا عن بعض الدول
الاوروبيه كلها تتجه الى هذا ربما
السياق بالتالي اذا ما كانت بالفعل هناك
مخاطر امنيه بناء عليه اتخذت مثل هذه
الدول هذا القرار الا يمكن ان ينسحب هذا
الخطر كذلك على التيك توك في السعوديه
احنا دائما اي قرار تاخذ الامريكي على
الشركات الصينيه بتلاقي التبعيا في اسبوع
واقل من اسبوع دول اوروبا تنقاد وراها
مباشره هذه الطبيعه راجع كل التطبيقات كل
الفترات الاخيره الاعلانات دائما بتلاقيها
في نفس السياق السعوديه ما فيها لو في اي
خطر امني صدقني هيئه الاتصالات
عندنا صارمه جدا في الامور هذه كلها اللي
عندك انت تروح الخوادم صينيه كما يقال
وانه اشتغل ربما من جهات ذات علاقه بهذا
الامر كما يقول كما كنت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والكثير من التقارير الغربيه
كذلك منسحب على الصين التي تملك هذه
المنصه
واي برنامج موجود على الانترنت عنده اعداد
كبيره جدا حيتم الاستفاده منه لما نيجي
نطالع في برنامج الواتساب تقريبا اغلب
يستخدمه ايش يخلي فيسبوك تشتري الواتساب
17 مليار ايش في عنده اصول هل عنده عماير
هل عنده عقارات هل عنده اسهم لا عنده
معلومات
الفيسبوك عندها انه السعوديه لن تتجه الى
مثل هذا القرار في رايك وانه حتى المبررات
او الاسباب
الاجتماعيه والاخلاقيه يعني لن تكون سببا
في ذلك او مؤثره خلال الفتره القادمه
ما اعتقد اعتقد السعوديه واضحه الشخص هذا
عباره عن سلوك شخصي وكل اب مسؤول عن
اطفاله في توقيت البرامج انه يعطيهم
صلاحيات البرامج تحت عمرك 12 سنه انت عندك
طفل انت حط صلاحيه على البرنامج بحيث انه
يبغى يطلب برنامج
على مسرعيه ما هو بيخش على اليوتيوب
شكرا جزيلا لك من جده الباحث فيها من
المعلومات ونظم الامنيه عادل الغامدي
فعاليات ضخمه واجازه ليوم واحد سيستمتع
بها طلاب وطالبات جده في غرب السعوديه
بمناسبه اقامه سباقات الفورملا للمره
الثالثه انطلق قبل قليل سباق جائزه
السعوديه الكبرى للعام 2023 في حرب في
حلبه كورنيش كورنيش جدا يشهد اليوم الاول
انتقال 20 سائقا من نجوم الفورمولا الى
سياراتهم في حصتين للتجارب الحره لمده
ساعه واحده على ان تتصاعد حده الاثاره يوم
السبت مع انتقال السائقيه الى المسار مره
اخرى
الانطلاق
ونذكر ايضا نورس لدي عادي جديد في سياره
هناندو الونسو يحاول الرد على سيرجيو فارس
حتى الان بدنا نذكر فارس الونس على اطارات
السوفت والانس ترول لم يدخل بعد رئيس
اتحاد او اداره الاتحاد السعودي للسيارات
والدرجات الناريه الامير خالد بن سلطان
الفيصلي ان حلبه سباق الفورمول في جده لم
تكن اعتياديه بل حازت على جوده عاليه
اشادت بها
زياره مرتقبه للرئيس الصيني الى روسيا
تؤكد الترحيب ببكين ايده ما استعادت
السلامه في اوكرانيا
تكشف عن موافقه ايران على وقف التسليح
الحوثين طهران امام اختبار حقيقي
ضوابط جديده لنظام ايقاف الخدمات في
السعوديه منصه موحده والضرر لا يتعدى
الموقوف
الضغوط الدوليه على تيك توك تتواصل
نيوزيلندا تحضره لاجل المخاوف الامنيه
جده تعيش تظاهره الفورمول فعاليات مصاحبه
والاحد اجازه رسميه للطلاب والطالبات
قبل بدايه الموسم تاكل اطارات كبير جدا عن
فريقك الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]